jetzt kommen zu einem ganz schrecklichen
fall ein toter junge in der donau und
keiner kennt ihn keiner vermisst ihn
ganz offenbar ein kind ohne leben und
ohne geschichte her unser reporter karl
heim ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet mit dem
neuesten informationen zu diesem fall
kann es ist so schwer zu verstehen es
werden ja derzeit
vermisstenanzeigen abgeglichen das ist
offenbar der polizei an einer spur fehlt
wer könnte dieser junge aus der donau
sein welche information hast du
ja die suche hier in vohburg an der
donau im landkreis pfaffenhofen das ist
etwas östlich von ingolstadt ii geht
jetzt weiter hier sucht die polizei mit
dem thw und einem sonargerät nach spuren
man hofft dass man hier gegenstände am
ja auf dem grund finden kann die etwas
mit der tat zu tun haben könnten oder um
auch auszuschließen dass hier nichts
gefunden wird des weiteren kommen wir
gleich noch leichenspürhunde zum einsatz
die ich noch mal den bereich rund um
diese stauanlage absuchen es ist ein
rätselhafter fall hier des
polizeipräsidiums oberbayern nord keiner
vermisst diesen jungen es werden jetzt
16 vermisstenfälle aus ganz bayern
abgeglichen die heiße spur soll noch
nicht dabei sein er man muss sagen es
war eine grusel haft eine grauenhafte
entdeckung die ein kanufahrer vor genau
zwei wochen gemacht hat da war der junge
eingepackt in eine plastikfolie
zusammengefaltet wie ein paket unter
etwa so verpackt dass er nie hätte
auftauchen sollen nun jetzt ist er hier
aufgetaucht und die der leichnam war
sehr stark verwest man konnte nicht mehr
mit dem bloßen augen erkennen was für
eine hautfarbe dieser junge gehabt hat
sich fest steht dass er im alter
zwischen vier und sechs jahren ist ja
er hat aber keine schuss und auch keine
stichverletzungen das hat eine
untersuchung der rechtsmedizin in
münchen ergeben jetzt
versuchen die rechtsmediziner
herauszufinden das dauert immer
unfassbar lange wurde dieser junge etwa
vergiftet ist er erstickt worden oder
sogar stranguliert und
denn dass es bei kindern häufig zuschuss
oder stichverletzungen kommt das ist
sehr ungewöhnlich aber auch das dauert
man konnte nicht mehr mit den bloßen
augen erkennen ob der für die
strangulation typischen rot
unterlaufenen augen hat selbst das
konnte man nichts mehr sehen so stark
war der leichnam mitgenommen verwest er
solche schon eine längere zeit in der
donau gelegen haben das konnte man
mittlerweile feststellen und das ist
jetzt das grenzt den suchradius gerade
nicht ein man konnte herausfinden dass
dieser junge eingepackt in plastikfolie
meese staustufen hätte überwinden können
und dadurch im jahr die donau entspringt
im schwarzwald in baden württemberg es
gibt viele zuflüsse dh der junge kann
überall sage ich mal im süd deutlichen
im süddeutschen bundesgebiet hier ins
wasser geworfen worden seien und man
erhofft sich heute hier weitere spuren
zu finden kann kein dankeschön für diese
ganz aktuellen informationen wirklich
sehr mysteriöser fall man kann nur
hoffen dass da bald licht ins dunkel
kommt